the congratulations on this very real
achievement how do you feel about having
the longest run ever in the land of
theater
well naturally i think it's wonderful
have you ever met a real criminal
ah maybe but i don't know if so
that was a rare interview of agatha
christie from 1958 she didn't grant many
interviews but her work
barely needs an introduction christy is
third
all-time in terms of books sold an
estimated
2 billion copies the only things ahead
of her
the bible and the works of william
shakespeare
but as people continue reading her
mysteries today many
have forgotten about the biggest mystery
in christie's own life
a sensational disappearance that took
place not long after world war one
that disappearance is the focus of a new
novel by marie benedict
jeff glor sat down with her the person
that she became on the other side
of this disappearance is very different
than the person
who started out ladies and gentlemen
agatha christie
the mystery began on a saturday night in
december 1926
agatha christie then an up-and-coming
writer at 36
suddenly went missing from her home in
england when i did some digging
and i learned that she actually
disappeared for 11 days
in circumstances that seemed torn from
the pages of one of her own novels
i became a little bit obsessed marie
benedict
has been uncovering and writing stories
about famous women in history for years
including albert einstein's first wife
maleva marich
clementine churchill and actress hedy
lamarr
now it's christy she really had to buck
against
what the expectations for women of her
time period were
to kind of rise up and seize her legacy
and
and her talents um but it came at a huge
cost
i'm just going away jane i'll give you a
message tomorrow
christy's disappearance was turned into
a movie with vanessa redgrave and dustin
hoffman in 1979.
which one was agatha christie is on her
with the fur but it's never received a
book treatment like this
benedict's the mystery of mrs christie
is told in alternating chapters
one part of the story focuses on the
author's background
how she became the most famous mystery
writer of all time
the other part imagines what happened
over the course of her disappearance
told through the perspective of her
unfaithful husband
a former world war one pilot named
archie christie
her husband um you know they married um
during world war one
uh when agatha was um serving actually
in the war
very rare for girls of her class she was
a nurse
and then she worked in a pharmacy which
is where she gathered her
her knowledge of poisons which she put
to use later
and when he emerged from the war in many
ways he was a very different person than
he had
started out benedict believes archie
christie may have suffered from a case
of ptsd
whatever the circumstances the strain
that developed in the christie marriage
came to a head
in 1926 christie was gone
and no one knew where thousands
volunteered for a search
and lakes were dragged as headlines were
splashed across newspapers worldwide
you think this window and the drama that
played out helped
launch her onto the next level right you
know when she disappeared she wasn't the
agatha christie that we think of today
she was
well established but not well known but
by the
end of this disappearance she was on
a completely different trajectory and
she really had become
a household name on december 15 1926
agatha christie was finally found at the
harrogate spa
more than 200 miles north of where she
lived outside london i
would like to book a room she was
checked in under the name of mrs neal
the surname of her husband's mistress
teresa
neil so what happened over those 11 days
no one knows exactly christy pleaded
amnesia
and never spoke about the episode again
even after she and
archie divorced a little more than a
year later even until she died in 1976
benedict's book blends facts with
fiction
meant to fill in the blanks i just
couldn't help but think that a woman
this brilliant this masterful at the art
of plotting
and creating masks behind which her
characters hide
how could she be a victim in her own
vanishing right
so that kind of idea and that my
understanding of who she was
really permeated the world i created of
her disappearance
the agatha christie who emerged after
the 11 day episode
was far more reclusive interviews were
few and far between
why are you so fascinated by crime
i don't know that i'm very fascinated by
it i've just begun writing about it then
one continues
that's what usually you know the story
that i've told she may not want to be
known but if she
were to somehow cycle back and actually
take a look at it
i hope she would see that it's really an
homage
to her to her intellect to her
perseverance to her ambition
and what what kind of came out the other
end of this
really the pivotal event in her life i
think was a
stronger more resilient woman and writer
wow brilliant masterful and apparently
she was a surfer
back then yeah i mean and i had no idea
about this part of her story it kind of
makes you wonder if that happened today
would there not be that mystery people
might know well this is actually where
she was that whole time but we'll never
know unsolved mystery the queen of
mystery
maybe we solve it if we read the book
that's right well there you go